imagine a world where diagnosing an
illness is as simple as getting blood
drawn where diseases can be targeted by
medicines with pinpoint accuracy where
drugs are perfectly tailored to a
patient's genetic makeup and produce no
side effects this world is the promise
of precision medicine and with the
growing ease with which personalized
health information can be collected many
believe now may be the best time to
start delivering on that promise at
precision medicine 2016 a virtual
conference hosted by lab roots experts
from industry academia and government
discuss the recent advances in
bioscience and clinical medicine that
are laying the groundwork for this
exciting endeavor at the forefront of
these efforts is the precision medicine
initiative announced in 2015 during
President Obama's State of the Union
address this initiative calls for 215
million dollars in funding for the
research and infrastructure needed to
support the development of personalized
medicine the last decade has witnessed
impressive advances in DNA sequencing
computational biology biomarker
detection and rational drug design and
today more people are engaging in
improving their health and participating
in health research than ever before to
build on this momentum the precision
medicine initiative calls for among
other developments the creation of a
national research cohort of 1 million
volunteers the medical information
shared by this large group will help
researchers discover new connections
among environmental factors genes
disease and therapeutic responses
keynote speaker dr. Eric shat professor
of genomics at the Icahn Institute for
genomics and multiscale biology
discusses what scientists can do with
the universe of data collected from
individuals capitalizing on the rapid
advancement of medical diagnostic
technology and the growing popularity of
wearable sensors and mobile apps
designed for health management
scientists can aggregate massive amounts
of data to create predictive models of
disease
these models dr. Schatz says can lead to
better diagnosis and treatments for
common and rare human diseases the
presenters at precision medicine 2016
approached the refinement of medical
treatments from many angles from the
technical and organizational challenges
of sequencing the genomes of many
volunteers to the computational
challenges of accessing and analyzing
these vast datasets to the design
challenge of creating treatments that
interact with cells and proteins in
desirable ways together the presenters
and participants of precision medicine
2016 are paving the way to a true
revolution in medicine and health
you